Should we rank herself.
She would just like close her eyes and like scoot to where we think we should go
here. How are we not going to bump into each other?
Did anyone take this into consideration? Sorry.
Can we say like what we do? Or like, so I'm a dancer.
I'm very physical. I use my body a lot. I love baking cakes.
I always just like shove baked goods on my friends.
I teach acting to young kids. I do mostly musical theater because I'm a weenie.
I know. Um, but I'm single as all.
Heck I am a journalism major.
I'm also a student I'm double majoring in psychology and criminal justice.
I'm also an actress. I love to travel. I've been to India five times.
We have to do this. Can we rank herself?
Should we just close our eyes and like scoop where we think we should then?
You know what I mean? Just go for it an individual basis. Very smart.
I feel like my personality is really attractive. My looks, I feel like I'm like,
okay. Like I don't think anyone would look at me and be like, who ha, Oh,
I'm nervous. How are we not going to bump into each other?
Did anyone take this into consideration? Sorry. We're all so humble. But like
what if you don't know?
Like which one is the number I saw almost s'mores too.
I didn't know where y'all were standing.
That girl who I found most attractive was Jordan.
She has a great personality and she's confident, dope. Oh, see,
I thought this is wait,
wait, wait, wait. It's five two.
How did I end up here?
Can we do it off as like immediate first impression and attraction to the
person? I'm just going to put it out there. Just say, just let me do it. One,
two, three, four, Oh, sorry. One,
two, three, four, one, two, three, four. Got it.
Um, one, two, three, four. Okay. One, two, three, four.
Okay. I'll be two because I got all 14. Okay. I think I got three,
four of the most, so I'll stick into that window.
Depending on the other persons,
there were attributes that I saw in the other girls that I didn't see in myself.
And hence I would've put them higher as well over me. So people are like, Oh,
she's so sweet. She's so funny. She looks, but like I wouldn't dinner.
I guess I'll be one. Okay. Okay. Cool.
Thanks so much dearly. And I would date a three.
Okay. Yeah. I'll just stay here. Yeah.
Nobody really wanted to be lost and I could kind of feel that vibe.
So I was just like, you know, it's fine. Like nobody is a five really?
I don't think so. But I mean,
where do you think you would fit yourself into something? Uh, well, I mean,
I don't know, because I feel like personality is a big thing
too. I would say three.
Let's say you don't have a personality, but I'm like, Oh, I'm five again.
I think we just put ourselves in order of most extroverted,
not the most personality. So this is fine. This is fine.
Do you want to start over there?
Like just shift down. I think Michelle was the most attractive, how she looked,
how she carried herself and it just seems like someone that's going to live an
exciting life. I guess you could say,
or that you can have like a deep conversation with, could you.
I forgot. They can't even hear me. Well,
what would you switch? I switched here you go.
Over there.
Personally, for me,
she kind of looks like Kristen bell and I really liked Chris and Mel, sorry,
Twitter. And on the one or two position. And I kind of like her vibe.
I think her whole aesthetic is very nice. So for me,
it's either one or two up here.
I think that Maria was the most attractive for me.
It was just like her whole vibe. And like, I liked how her hair was,
how her makeup was done. Like she looked very nice.
Are we content with five being five Or at least three?
So five goes up. She should be a four because it's like meeting the middle.
Five and four switch.
We're going to rip the new one.
That's a good pointer here. Guys are not afraid to be more blunt.
They were straight up. Hey, you're attractive. You're attractive. You're not.
But girls were like, I don't want to be rude. You know,
we're all beautiful in our own way. Are we good?
We're good. I'm good.
I feel bad.
The way the guys were ranking the girls.
I actually think we were doing it mostly by personality.
I was super anxious about ranking. My hands were getting all clammy.
I was like really uncomfortable being the one to be like putting.
Them where I thought it's obviously something that we do like in day-to-day life
would rank people subconsciously,
but having to do it like in front of them and like them watching you ranked
them, was it wasn't fun, but definitely a memorable experience
while I was at five.
And now I'm here. So I'm like, thank you. I don't know. It's very interesting.
I feel, I did think coming into this,
like cultural stereotypes would be a factor.
Them raking me first kind of shot that down I guess,
because I didn't think they would choose like an Asian girl first.
I think when I think of a male viewing me as attractive or not versus a female,
it's definitely different because in a male setting, if of judging me,
I knew that was going to happen. Like I'm not stupid.
So like I'm aware of how others view me.
I was surprised at them placing me at the bottom. But at the same time,
I know out of a room of beautiful girls that I was put in that from the jump
there was, there was no chance for me. I was, yeah, that chance there,
me being the only black girl, like I knew that I wouldn't be rank,
right? Yeah.
American beauty standards versus what people see people of color it's different.
But guys that I interact with,
they socialize more with black women and they think more black women are
attractive.
I think that the guys ranked the woman from appearance more than personality.
Most of the time,
I feel like it just confirms that attractiveness is so subjective and circled
and presented in one way. And always has been,
even though I have my days where I'm like, Oh,
you not really that cute and days where I'm like, Ooh, you like you,
you cute. I would say I wouldn't change.
I wouldn't change.
I feel like he, he would give you flowers, timeout
movies.